[Music]
one day
pirate just disappeared
[Music]
i couldn't find her anywhere
[Music]
it was as if she vanished off the face
of all rest
a trace where have you gone
i'll find you whatever it takes
this is where you were pyra
sorry rex i couldn't tell you
because i got an invitation to join
trash
i thought i was gonna be in smash just
sit back and leave it to me
rex behold the power of the egypt
[Music]
the piranha is smash attack with fire
[Music]
there are no pushovers
talk about a tight spot mithra
let me handle this
[Music]
mithra cutting it close huh
hey were these guys planning on running
gee i feel kind of bad now
coming through rising
buster
[Music]
you can even use
[Music]
quite the spectacle aren't they
wait grumps ah i've missed this
everybody
monday by once a while
oh look our friends are here and there's
a poor
[Music]
old
squad
[Music]
i never expected to see you two again
[Music]
well now that you're in smash
i won't go easy on you fighting words
you forget we're fighters too
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cash
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
elder i have important news
so it's finally beginning go assemble
the villagers
50 years ago kamuro village was attacked
by the rampage and magnum bolo
and we suffered some devastating
casualties
how can we fight against that our hunter
is about to face the biggest challenge
yet
no we can't lose this gauge
pull yourself together you're not
getting it
go rampage somewhere else
[Music]
the rampage how long do you think it's
going to last
you noah we should start preparations
right away
we're here to offer assistance
we must stop the calamity
as above so below
why do they need assassins in heaven
to do someone's dirty work
so
it's kill or be killed you won't last
long if you can't rely on yourself
[Music]
god's judgment has nothing to do with it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he leaves us no recourse swords
s ross will answer for its crimes today
are these the wages of loyalty raised
earth and burnt corpses
you and no other must decide how we
proceed
you are a leader and must be the beacon
others look to when the night is darkest
together with these fields today you
burn i promise to do all in my power to
see us through this safely
every last one of us
[Music]
wow
it's about to get electricity
[Music]
right
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
everybody get up
the fairway is open once again
tee off on the latest installment of the
mario golf series
coming to nintendo switch study the wind
and terrain
take your time to think things through
then swing
enjoy golfing with familiar mushroom
kingdom characters
on courses filled with lush natural
scenery
use features on the greens like a shock
gauge to see how your shot will curve
due to slopes
and a scan that lets you examine a
course's terrain
[Music]
these features can help you ace your
shots
[Music]
in addition to button controls you can
also use motion controls
by holding a joy-con controller like a
golf club
gently swing the controller to have your
character swing in the game
letting you easily enjoy the sensation
of golfing
on top of all that there are several
modes with new elements
that truly bring the heat to mario golf
including this one
speed golf here it's always your turn
everyone tees off at the same time then
you'll race through the course to reach
your ball
give it another whack to get it closer
to the hole then keep going
outpace your opponents to come out on
top your golfing skills aren't the only
things
at play make use of dashes and special
shots to beat the competition
oh did we mention story mode
as a me character you'll start out as a
rookie and develop your golfing skills
while interacting with various mushroom
kingdom characters
level up with experience points earned
during matches
then allocate points to different stats
allowing you to develop your character
however you'd like you can also use your
me
in versus play put your golfing skills
to the test
when mario golf super rush swings onto
nintendo switch
june 25th pre-orders begin on nintendo
eshop
after this presentation super mario
brothers 35th anniversary themed items
are coming to the animal crossing new
horizons game
familiar items like the super mushroom
and the question block can be ordered
in-game as furniture items
so place them however and wherever you'd
like
[Music]
you can also place two warp pipes
then use them to travel between
locations on your island
hey why not try recreating the mushroom
kingdom
[Music]
a free update for the game launches
february 25th
[Music]
after downloading it super mario
brothers items will be available via
nook shopping starting march 1st
keep an eye on the official animal
crossing twitter account for the latest
information
we hope you continue enjoying life on
your island hang on tight
because you're all going to play a
little game of fate for
me from the creators of the danganronpa
and zero escape series comes a fight for
your life
literally disoriented and trapped in an
underwater theme park
the 12 of you known as the go getters
club must now survive this game of fate
at all
costs i don't want to die yet
sorry to scare you all but the
game is cancelled the game is suddenly
called off
you escape the theme park and get a
glimpse of japan but
everyone's vanished set off on a
captivating journey across the country
that blends side-scrolling action with
suspenseful narratives
as you make your way back home to tokyo
you'll alternate between working solo
and teaming up with the group to
overcome challenges and monsters that
stand in your way
what awaits you all at the end of your
journey the battle for survival begins
in world's end club venturing onto
nintendo switch
may 28th aliens have invaded earth
hold up is this even the right game
anyway
after annihilating an entire city the
aliens have taken over
and now hosts an intergalactic superhero
ranking tournament to decide earth's
fate
here we go as the crass beam katana
wielding assassin travis touchdown
you'll need to fight your way to the top
to save the world
hey hey not so fast to enter each boss
fight
you'll have to do some odd jobs around
town and earn enough to pay off the
entry fee
you'll then face off against the slew of
unusual opponents
most of them aliens with some crazy
tricks up their sleeves
study their tactics carefully to gain
the upper hand in combat
with a new and improved death glove
you'll have access to a variety of
deadly skills that can be customized and
upgraded before each match
the fate of the world is at stake so get
ready to kick some
uh whatever aliens have that you can
kick
anyway it'll all make sense when no more
heroes 3 lands on earth
or you know nintendo switch august 27th
you